San Francisco Chronicle reports on the
controversy over violent content posted
on Facebook like the video of the
Cleveland killing in a statement
facebook said the crime in the graphic
shooting video quote goes against our
policies and everything we stand for
John Blackstone is in san jose
california where Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg is set to address the
company's annual Developers Conference
John good morning good morning well Mark
Zuckerberg keynote speech of this
conference always draws widespread
attention but the public scrutiny is
particularly intense today well it's not
clear if he'll address Sunday's killing
there's no doubt that the company needs
to folk in on afford to ignore this
issue today is the Easter Sunday join a
massacre a day after Steve Stevens used
Facebook to tell the world about his
gruesome crime the company admitted we
know we need to do better the video of
the murder was viewed at least twenty
two thousand times and 1200 users shared
it Facebook released a timeline saying
Stevens uploaded the video at to 11 p.m.
eastern time Sunday it wasn't reported
until almost two hours later at 359
after that report it took 23 minutes
until his page was disabled the mood of
Facebook right now is somber and
reflective Deepa Seetharaman a reporter
at The Wall Street Journal says Facebook
is dealing with the fact that more than
60 violent acts have been posted on its
live feeds since last year's accelerated
roll out when they were working on this
product last year they thought about
some of the downsides but speed was
primary currently if Facebook users see
a violent or offensive live video they
can click on the options tab and click
report video when asked what's going on
they have multiple choices including
violence facebook says it's working to
make that process easier for its 1.9
billion monthly users and it says quote
we are constantly exploring ways that
new technologies can help artificial
intelligence plays an important part
still critics say artificial
intelligence
as its limits now we have to start
thinking about collaborative solutions
that are a combination of user reports
employee driven monitoring and automated
algorithms at the time is now if not
years ago that we have to start getting
more aggressive right now Facebook
relies almost entirely on its users to
report inappropriate content but as the
Cleveland case clearly shows sometimes
people are quicker to share videos with
their Facebook friends than they are
with Facebook authorities Norman it's a
good point John thank you I mean think
about that here they're having their big
conference today marks up Mark
Zuckerberg speaking and they've got to
deal with this controversy this Facebook
killer on the loose good timing though
to bring it all out and have this
conversation it's very important time
for going issue for them your a is gonna
do somethin about ya